empires have fallen religions have been
replaced the city itself has changed
names but the dome of the higher Sofia
has withstood it all built in the 6th
century as a Byzantine church it was for
centuries the world's largest Christian
Cathedral almost a millennium later it
was converted into an Islamic mosque
during the Ottoman Empire but in the
1930s it was turned into a museum under
the founder of the modern Turkish
Republic Ataturk a symbol of the new
secular state inclusive of all religions
since then it has been a meeting point
of many faiths but held by none a place
where Pope's and presidents have come to
pay their respects and marvel at the
architecture but religion is a tool for
president red chip type yovan he has
overseen prayers in the museum and
raised its status at local election
rallies as you know they converted the
higher Sofia from a mosque to a museum a
while ago now we hope to be able to call
it a mosque again after the elections
lammott groups have fought to pray at
the higher sofia angering neighboring
greece which says the building is part
of its orthodox christian history UNESCO
has warned Turkey its conversion to a
mosque could violate the world cultural
heritage convention
a flashpoint of religious and national
struggle whatever its future the higher
Sofia will remain an icon of Istanbul
and standing by in front of the higher
Sofia itself is Istanbul correspondent
Julia and Julia tell us about the
importance of this building and what's
at stake today with the court's decision
well just standing here right in front
of the aya sofia looking at it it really
is an architectural masterpiece with an
incredibly interesting history a
cultural landmark for both Christians
and Muslims and it attracted a nearly 4
million visitors last year and these are
probably reasons why there is always so
much attention especially from abroad
whenever there is a debate here in
Turkey about this building's future and
there have been many such debates in the
past now today turkey's top
administrative court reviewed another
challenge to the iso fears museum status
it was brought forward by a turkish
association that claims there is a
problem with the legality of the 1934
document by which it was turned into a
museum by turkey's state founder Mustafa
Kemal atatürk they say there's something
wrong with that document and needs to be
ruled invalid now as we learned from
Turkish media reports the court earlier
in the morning had a short session and
came up with a verdict but they won't
announce the verdict today but say they
will publish a written statement
sometime within the next 15 days now
there is a lot of speculation why they
don't make their decision public but
what I can tell you is for sure this
debate surrounding the idea Sofia will
continue it will go on let's talk with
more about the politics of this the
president erawan is a conservative
Muslim himself he supports plans to
change the high as a fierce status to a
mosque why is that important for him
well you could all argue that Istanbul
already has more than three thousand
mosques including many representatives
once so the city doesn't need another
mosque but it's not about this
the aya sofya is the ultimate symbol of
the Muslim Ottoman conquest of Christian
Constantinople and Edwin knows that he
is known as a politician who uses
religious and nationalist symbolism to
draw support from his conservative
voters why is this issue coming up now
many critics say he's trying to divert
attention from other pressing issues the
coronavirus crisis has hit the Turkish
economy hard his approval ratings
including those of his parties have
dropped so the higher Sofia from that
perspective it's somewhat like a
political joke a card aired on place
from time to time well if they change
the status into a mosque what kind of
international reactions can expect well
that would be hugely controversial it's
safe to expect a lot of criticism from
the Orthodox Church from Greece Russia
yesterday US Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo has urged Turkey to maintain the
museum status here of the aya sofya he
called it a place that is considered a
bridge between cultures and religions so
a transformation of the museum into a
mosque would certainly come with a lot
of risks especially on the international
level it might help help out on
domestically for a certain time it might
be somewhat like a triumph here
domestically but internationally this
could turn into a problem for him GWS
Julia Hahn at the hires of fear in
Istanbul thank you